also tonight the Ingram angle is
exposing poor border leadership like in
the state of New Mexico we don't talk
about New Mexico much but we're going to
do this tonight where they're citizens
by the way deserve a heck of a lot
better
yesterday led by the Democratic governor
Michelle Grisham the state of New Mexico
and the City of Albuquerque sued the
Trump administration over its Asylum
policies now the state wants to release
asylum seeking migrants into local
communities and then claim reimbursement
for humanitarian efforts to shelter them
joining me now is Andrea Moore Secretary
of the Republican Party of New Mexico
all right Andrea what do you say about
the situation in the state I think it's
absolutely deplorable to use a term that
we on the right have been given we are
County cities and villages are just
absolutely at capacity and the limited
resources that they already have are
being stretched thin because they are
being forced to house the illegal
immigrants that are crossing our border
now Andrea you and I ran into each other
on a plane and we just started talking
about stuff and I had no idea who you
were and we're just chatting and I don't
think you knew who I was just chatting
and he started telling me the story of
New Mexico which has become a pretty
solidly Democrat State I think the Trump
administration thinks that they have a
chance to flip that state back to the
Republican Party given what's happened
at a Democrat leadership in the state
just on the issue of immigration do you
think this is possible
oh absolutely with the continued failing
policies of our governor our state is
primed to be flipped back to read and
vote for Trump as well as all of our
wonderful conservative Republicans up
and down the ticket all right Andrea
thank you so much we'll be checking back
with you soon